welcome to this video playing king
joshey morph okay yeah nice and low
paying tribute to the late arugula gosh
emo it's got a super hydrating they're
pretty new account so let's see what and
what happens it's Collins airy flag
there so got a sloth not not yet i did
have not played i have not yet played d4
but probably will but later okay just a
good normal development yeah that's a
good way to play for black so are you
going on I p5 is not right here not be
five Bishop before check and then I'm in
trouble yeah I tend to screw these
dispositions up I really tend to i play
this i don't really know it too well
okay that he played a six very quickly
so maybe we're still in in normal
territory Roxy one i wonder if i should
take play night a for trade trade some
pieces off okay let's do that you can of
course drop back with the bishop okay he
didn't just took just playing in a
simple way which is of course also fine
so we had 94 93 years i see hmm it's a
bit uncomfortable my I porn is a bit
weak so probably that wasn't a great way
to play and how am I going to do this
him and a pawn apron is busy is a
problem
I really don't want to go a four but how
am I not losing the pawn I can take and
play play a queen move like a queen be
one or something or queen a one looks
very unnatural but a 4 also didn't look
too great yeah as i said i am not really
a huge expert on this opening and it's
quite often shows if the black player
knows his stuff yeah my night on b2 is
entirely ridiculous maybe I can improve
it a little bit Knight d2 is blundering
YouTube before so that's not happening
ok yeah I thought Queen d2 would be
quite ok or not I thought that looks
okay Oh interesting interesting but I
think ok I can take it takes e 2 e
chicks there yeah maybe um or what about
before is this a better move probably
not let's just take Josh's take thinking
night c5 but Bishop Bishop g5 is
probably a good reply and I still what
else what else is there ok so his he has
Bishop to c6 in many situations I wonder
if 97's actually a move somehow look see
arrow he will probably just take and see
one
how bad is Queenie one let's try again
ever get an a4 a5 all the trade queens
with activation of my rook my time is of
course an issue maybe I'm but maybe this
is now it's just not good yeah the night
is not a good piece if I've I did not
expect isn't this quite ok now I'm going
to block him here
the bishop was the much stronger minor
piece but now I'm not so sure and there
are some little tricks and like rook da
drug d 6 quite quite funny um maybe rook
these six anyway and then rugby one okay
I'll so I have my background my back
rank now that that was probably not a
good choice threatening b6 now so I'm
going here and my background is weak
really easy i shouldn't have played
rugby six where's he going I don't know
I just trying to trim milk yeah of
course so I have to this probably the
IROC t6 was just completely completely
wrong bit of a mindless smooth yeah put
in ridiculous position for this rook
I hope I'm not losing it somehow Darin
like directly the only thing that really
keeps me from falling apart is that I
have this pressure on the bb7 point it's
not getting getting rid of that so
easily
hmm if it wasn't for this this
completely bare wrong route it wasn't
put be that bad like the rook on d2 or
something i would really be quite
optimistic then I mean not like way I'm
winning but looks much could have look
much better that way okay let's make
sure be six is not happening time
morning no cannot spend much more time
here this maruca's somehow playing a
little bit yeah this kind of this is
interesting you're just just trying to
take their now a cheek b7 is God look
back that is going to enter here Brooke
each one has a huge problem and it's all
a huge problem maybe you could be check
to check check
check check check check I had some made
that's just made check I can rock g1 and
takes on h4 is going to win yeah the
city look t6 move I really was
completely okay in this position check
complete here come on i'm giving up here
why it was entirely entirely eotech yeah
Luke to d6 I mean he had a good position
but I think I think that this is just
wrong it's just wrong move cannot
believe in that maybe maybe yeah okay um
in any case in any case I'm totally fine
but Rock t6 is just a gap it's just
completely unnecessary if I go f3 king
f2 I'm completely fine there's nothing
wrong with my position here i have this
counter play against the pawns and
antioquia computer is on 0 I don't have
this problem with the with the rook the
way it went I maybeee votes the engine
is giving what g4 maybe but it just
found more difficult now yeah with this
this offside rook ladyship on to d6
again it's just a liability and my piece
has huge problems there okay according
to the engine everything's still fine
but it's it's not easy to play they
wanted to get it into play which I
managed but now he's invading and black
wins now I cannot take care I thought
actually because of rook p 8 which is
not given by the engine and because the
zoo Kings oops that was stupid but rook
h1 is a is a winner probably now he's
got two loops and the strong bishop
attacking that's going to
it's not ending we're back check check
I'm just losing it's just hard to
difficult to play with that offside Peas
I should but I didn't really I didn't
see at all I just I was just thinking
let's put this on an active spot and
play rugby one and only then a bit later
when he went here only here which is far
too late I realized the problem with the
whole thing um d 5 is given by the
engine let's let's analyze this a little
bit I actually thought about the move
briefly but I didn't see enough
compensation here here I didn't see a
move I can do this of course of course I
mean I saw that but i forgot that i have
to check check that sets quite neat and
this should be a draw maybe check yeah
yeah that's a drag he cannot go over to
the B file has to go back and I'm just
taking there and play whatever it should
be a draw I can actually give checks I
think yeah yeah that that was one way to
draw yeah I played it played it nicely
so on one running short so what's the
opening which put me Annie and end under
an immediate pressure ok well thanks for
watching